[Music]
sarah
swen welcome you are first
what is up everybody oh it's the finale
oh it's so sad
isn't it sad it's like awesome but it's
sad oh
man
all right let me just check the audio
real quick
oh nope there we go it's sounding good
let's pull up disney plus on the other
screen here
oh guys i have no idea and girls i have
no idea what to expect
i'm so nervous
i'm so nervous i
i literally have no idea was paul
bettany trolling us
like like what is happening right i mean
is nightmare gonna show up is it
mephisto is it c'thun
like i'm so
i don't want to expect anything because
it's 50 minutes long i guess we called
that
wait can i watch it now
can we watch it now it's out oh my gosh
i can't watch it come on
let me watch it
error code i guess you probably can't
watch it until is anybody actually
watching it
is anybody actually watching it it
doesn't say
yeah i don't is anybody actually
watching it
yeah can anybody see it though because
like
like how do i do this
so when i try to do it when i try to do
it
it doesn't actually let me watch it it's
just an error code
so
i i don't think you can actually watch
it until 12.
ah i'm back
i don't think i can actually watch it
you're watching it now why can't
i watch it
it says it's out but i wonder when it
came out
yeah i don't think it's out i i can't
watch it i just keep getting error code
i don't think it's going to be i don't
think we're going to be able to
hey brianna how's it going thanks for
super chat
can you watch it right now
i hope you've been well brianna i always
remember you
nine minutes left this is the final
episode i see a few people asking in the
chat right now yeah it's it is the final
episode
okay my boys over at the real rejects
told me
away so i don't miss any super chats
because i don't want to miss any
and they sent me
they just sent me away how at the top
where's the section at the top i don't
have a section at the top
oh okay okay okay do i have it here this
is how it works
nope am i still alive
huh weird
well dramand oliver thank you so much
for that super chat
i'm really trying not to
really try not to miss any guys i
apologize if i do
hello wavy d productions you're watching
it
i can't watch it
i guess we just keep trying right
carlos thank you for that super chat in
france it's already on while i'm trying
let's
kendrick what's up man i do think doctor
strange is going to show up thank you
super chat daniel d
oh thank you i appreciate that i yeah i
can't get it
i am clicking it for all people saying
click it i'm clicking it it's not
working
now we had a we had a problem last time
hey praj goon squad thanks for super
chat i'm so excited
i have no idea what to expect
all right okay here we go here we go
okay sorry i hope you know i can't show
the whole thing
okay snooper's gonna snoop
so this is just the previously part
here we go here we go here we go
it's just a recap right now
whoo
this is right in my way
scarlett witch and here it goes
what a vision finale oh is this double
i don't want this to be double test test
test
okay it's off cool cool cool cool hype
still the logo
and here we go
super chef what day will be so hype i'm
so hyped too
thank you it started here we go
my powers work out here
oh oh
god here she told the kids to go to your
room
and then dagota said listen to your
mother
ho yo they're straight up fighting
oh
i take power from the undeserving
oh snap she's like taking power from her
oh dang
surrender your magic
and i'll let you keep the world
ah she hit her with a car
she just hit agatha straight up with a
car
dang
ha that is definitely a
wow that's really funny that's
definitely a wizard of oz
a wizard of oz thing oh snap
whose voice is it
this is not going to be good this is not
going to be good
nope dude do not dude no
dude he's gonna she's gonna he's gonna
rip your head off
ah
oh snap who was that oh og vision
and white vision of fighting
look at that he said where are the boys
oh snap vision v vision
oh snap that looks awesome
this is our home then let's fight for it
oh the two visions going at it
oh she's trapped monica's trapped with
quicksilver
quicksilver's just playing guitar
oh so now monica and quicksilver are
gonna fight
oh this is amazing
oh my gosh
so white vision is there oh he's oh he
was gonna try to take the stone out of
his head
oh snap oh stop
stupid hayward oh he got jimmy woo he
captured jimmy
oh jimmy's stealing stuff
heyward said if told jimmy if only you
had a little more vision
i love jimmy wood this guy's amazing
jimmy wu breaking out of handcuffs
magic and he's got a phone
all right here we go back to wanda
fighting agatha
i wonder if agatha is gonna like seek
the town on her
hey
the mailman again he said don't shoot
i'm just a messenger
oh i got the grabbed one to hit her
oh
[Music]
she said darkhold she called the book
the darkhold oh and she
her power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme
is what agatha said it's your destiny to
destroy the world
daddy
dang oh so she's
agatha's taking everybody out of the
trance and everybody knows it's wanda
doing it to her
oh they're going at her now too
everybody's going up to
oh wanda we go
meanwhile quicksilver is making a
smoothie
all right we're gonna what's the deal
here
my man cave
is quicksilver ralph quicksilver's ralph
quicksilver's ralph his name's ralph
boner
that's hilarious
oh my gosh
oh snap i knew it i
she was controlling quicksilver with her
bracelet
oh my gosh this vision white vision
versus regular vision fight is insane
the twins
ah billy can see them
oh the twins are going to help
when you let us sleep we have your
nightmares
what
foreign
what the heck is happening oh snap
oh she's choking all them with her
powers holy crap
oh my gosh
i got this telling her to let everybody
go
oh is she doing it oh she's doing it
she's getting rid of the town
oh she's getting rid of the hex
she's letting them out
she's letting them out but she only
opened up like a tiny portion of it
you're running the wrong way people come
on
dang
meanwhile visions are fighting
oh
oh vision's losing power because of the
hex is going away
yeah i think we're gonna lose vision
here
i think we're gonna lose vision here oh
no
oh yeah vision's not gonna have a good
time
oh vision's gonna die he's like going
away
the twins are here oh they're dying too
oh my gosh
she's bringing them back in yep
oh and he's back the twins are back
oh she's protecting them for those of
you saying show the video i obviously
can't just stream it it's illegal
we do this every week i just show parts
of it
oh snap one is getting
her magic is like agatha's taking her
magic away
and there's white vision
and swords here now
they're all showing up oh snap oh here
it is here's that scene
oh that's epic
oh snap
oh oh my gosh the
twins are about to fight too vision of
evision again
why are you doing this
my programming director is to destroy
the vision
but you are the vision
no
oh
oh what is happening here
oh so white vision said
oh snap back at those kicking people's
butts
oh snap
she was going to kill him and want to
save them
oh my gosh she just told the twins to
handle the military
oh snap wanda just disappeared all right
twins what you gonna do
look at that
oh photons here
oh whoa
that's insane
oh he stopped the bullet
she's gonna lose her boys
hayward you coward he's running away now
oh darcy's ripped darcy just rammed him
she said have fun in prison let's do it
let's do it
he looks evil
oh my gosh they're gonna they're gonna
fuse
they're gonna fuse oh my gosh
oh oh
white vision is realizing that he's a
weapon that's being controlled
he's starting to realize he's not
they're both realizing they're both not
to true vision
but together they are
vision's about to un vision's about to
awaken
the white vision oh snap
he's seen everything everything that the
normal vision went through look at that
wow wait does he still have the mind
stone no he doesn't
whoa
while they see each other now like
are they about to fuse he says i
envision
oh he left where is he going
he he left where did white vision go he
just
left
now i got this sitting there oh oh
that's insane
what wanda just happened to her mind
she's back to where the witches were
oh snap oh that's creepy whoa
is this nightmare it has to be nightmare
these are like knife or
nightmare freaking
are they about to like what is about to
happen
oh they're turning on her
all the witches are turning on wanda
you are the scarlet witch
no they got wanda they got her and now
they're putting her at the stake dang
oh she said power isn't her problem it's
knowledge
oh snap oh
look at that
no snap wanda is not giving up her
powers
oh
and now the witches are fighting
oh vision vision just stopped wanda stop
division
which we witch no
oh i got this taking it from wanda
what you got jimmy wu this episode is 50
minutes long for those of you who keep
asking
oh i got those taking her power
oh
wanda's dying
oh juan is actually giving her the power
now what is wanda
oh
you so she gave the power to agatha what
does that mean
[Music]
oh her powers don't work
why don't her powers work that's freaky
oh she's back now
oh whoa whoa whoa what has happened oh
she she cast a spell
yes she did wow
look at that that's crazy
runes
oh look
oh
[Music]
what is she doing she's taking it all
back in
yep
she's taking all her power back
please wear the suit please wear a
scarlet witch suit
oh yes here it is
wow wow
look at that the scarlet witch
wow
oh
okay this says you don't know what
you've done
is it because it's c'thun this is the
elder god
well now he's uh she's on the floor and
we have the scarlet witch
look at that wow
she says i'll lock you up here and give
you the role you chose the nosy neighbor
you have no idea what you unleashed
you're gonna need me
if i do i'll know where to find you
oh and she's normal now look at that
she says you have no idea what you
unleashed that is
the elder god
so what about the kids and vision
oh vision's aware that he
oh no she's she's gonna lose them all
no no she's gonna lose them all
no
no the vision and the kids aren't gonna
make it oh everything's turning back to
normal
oh the kids aren't gonna make it
they're going back home so they can
essentially die
dang
duh
they're in normal clothes now oh she's
gonna lose the kids
oh no
oh my gosh look at this
kids are in bed
oh
we can never truly leave each other even
if we tried they're about to die
but they're going to be reincarnated
like in the comics
no this is not good
she's saying bye to everybody vision
knows he's gonna die
but the kids don't know
she's about to they're all about to go
away
here comes the hex yep
he said boys thanks for choosing me to
be your mom
i wonder if that means anything
dang oh no everything's going back
well she's about to lose them
oh no no no no what's about to happen
here don't
don't take it away
she turned she just turned the light off
she's turning this light off now
one envisioner saying bye oh
all right here it comes here comes the
hex
and they're ready for it no
no no no no no no
vision says what am i
oh
oh he's the piece of the mind stone that
lives inside of her
vision is her sadness and hope
oh but mostly you're my love
they're saying bye
oh he cried
here it comes no
no you're really good
here it comes oh no
oh you're really going to make me watch
it oh no
no
[Music]
no he's going away
no
no
oh no he said so long darling
and it's all gone
oh i feel so bad for rwanda
no everything's gone the twins are gone
vision's gone
oh
and she puts her hood on and leaves
oh man all right guys i have to avoid
the chat right now because i know some
people have seen it
like a few minutes early so i don't need
to know what happens i want to witness
these post credit scenes by myself
and she's she's going back to the sword
people now
or the town people
ooh everyone's looking at her
everyone's looking at her
now we have wanda and monica talking
uh well
it's just monica and i'm talking
talking uh she said i'm sorry for all
the pain
wanda says she doesn't understand this
power but she will she knows she's going
to dr strange
she knows she's going to dr strange
the post credit scene has to be her like
showing up to the sanctum
oh she turns to the girl when she's
getting left
she's just flying through she's just
freaking
flying through oh
oh that's dope look at that
wow it's the scarlet witch what an
awesome costume that they gave her
all right all right show me the post
credits
what do we have for the post credits
okay here's one
all right post credit scene
there oh hey words being arrested
they're asking for you in the theater
captain rambo
i bet you the aerospace engineer is the
scroll
i bet you that's who her contact was i
bet you was a scroll just given her
connection to captain marvel
post-credits scene
is that her i was sent by an old friend
of your mother so i did it look at it so
scroll
he'd heard you've been cracked
oh she's going to suppose
it's got to be talos or fury
she said i met with an old friend of
your mother it's grounded all right
there's another post credit scene
and here it is okay okay wanda
one just went to a cabin like it looks
like
spoilers coming people here's wanda
lovely one though
i can't read chat right now guys i
haven't i'm watching the post credit
scene right now
what are you going to show us is doctor
strange gonna pop up
oh what is this
no
oh snap she has
the dark cold look
at that
what wow
and that's it
wow wow
almost nothing
that we thought was kind of right
no secret cameos
but i think i was right about c'thun
she said agatha said you have no idea
what you unleashed
and that has to be c'thun especially
with the dark hold
so when i said in my tweet today that i
was
i could be 90 right about all the stuff
that's happened i think i was 99
or there's a 90 chance i i was wrong
about everything there was
i was totally right only about like one
percent of things that's hilarious
all right that's uh
wow
wow wow wow wow
oh my gosh what is up guys hold on
hold on whoa okay
hold on let me get you guys on my screen
uh
so much to talk about man uh
hold on
right
no no and i was actually like as i as i
as she said you know nothing can really
keep his part whatever whatever that
line was that she said right i was like
they're coming back just like they do in
the comics they're gonna be reincarnated
as actual people
like whatever soul and yeah whatever
soul is out there and white vision's
gone
and he's real he's real he just dipped
he's like
oh wait i'm vision bye like
like i'm out oh my gosh
yeah yeah
so i i sent out a tweet before it
started and i was like
i was probably wrong about ninety
percent of the things i was wrong
at like ninety nine percent of the
things oh like
you know paul bettany he trolled us and
that uh
that's kind of funny i gotta give it to
paul bettany
um hey david roygas
right i think that's what he did yeah
for sure
yeah now
i think they'll they'll kind of bring
him into the fold as
vision the new yeah and this is
essentially what happens in the comics
is they build a new vision he doesn't
really have any of the memories and they
try to kind of give him memories and
that's essentially what vision did he
gave that
white vision his memories and then he
dipped like he was just like oh i'm the
real vision
later yeah but hey
i am absolutely shocked we did not see
steven strange
oh i know i know
like i thought for sure that was going
to be the second post-credits scene was
yeah
because i was like i was going to pull
up on her because yeah well i thought
she was like i don't understand this
power i can't control it but i i will
she's going to
say i'm like she has to go to the
sanctum right that's like what it's got
to be
that's what she's doing but that's a
that's we heard the name drop
right yeah i heard the name drop wait we
did when yeah
agatha agatha said um you are more
powerful than the sorcerers
oh sorcerer supreme right right yeah so
okay
one thing i have been talking about for
let's say the past like two weeks was
kathun
the elder god yeah that's she that's
he's totally coming because she's like
you have no idea what you unleashed
that's his book the darkhold she called
it by name so that's like
he's coming she confirmed the dark hold
it's not the other ones that some people
were saying it might have been it
is the dark hold that is made it's
literally the evil scrolls from
like boys chatted up i'm gonna use the
bathroom right now chat it up
oh david rodriguez thank you for the
super chat i thought it was great hold
on brad sorry two seconds
diego perez i thought it was a great
series as well thanks for the super chat
i'm glad it's your first time here
welcome
you picked a good one to join agroblaze
the ending of the show makes sense
but i'm disappointed that or i didn't
notice a house of end moment um
the whole series was kind of a house
event moment as far as like
creating creating you know different
realities but
i don't know brad i i'm surprised that
i'm surprised that the twins didn't make
it out because i thought maybe because
she actually birthed them
they'd make it you know what i'm saying
like i thought that
yeah that's fair because she didn't like
just magically create them
uh like clearly she did vision she yeah
a part of her
so well yeah like a part of her actually
made these kids so now i have to think
back like because i've always been stuck
on
house of m she brings she actually
brings people back to life
in that story yep and i thought that was
kind of
gonna be what it was like quicksilver is
actually dead
and then she creates a new reality where
he's alive and she gets rid of that
reality and he's back alive again same
with hawkeye so i'm just kind of like
yeah yeah i also think it was
interesting how
you know when agatha was talking about
you don't know what you've unleashed
i mean i feel like her power in general
is going to fracture the multiverse
oh yeah and just create a lot of
problems on that front so
uh yeah i mean i think now uh we have
our answer
uh when is secret invasion supposed to
launch do we know
we haven't done that no they're shooting
in april so i'm guessing early 2022.
okay so there's so there's no way that
drops obviously before
no way home so where where are we
getting our answers
and to how everything ties into
you know no way home well well i don't
think
i don't think secret invasion is
necessarily gonna tie into no way home
i think it's gonna more tie into captain
marvel too so that oh
no i don't know for sure but i'm saying
in general in the grand scheme of things
we didn't get the tie in
to the next you know big mcu film right
directly tied right right honestly i
think we see
wanda in no way home like we have to at
this point
yeah but but are we going to see
anything happen i mean
yeah yeah cause like before then nothing
that nothing that happened
as of right now can directly influence
the events of nowhere home
that's what i'm saying so like i i i i
still am baffled that we didn't see
strange
i mean me too yeah
there better be a good explanation when
the time comes because
that makes absolutely zero sense to me
oh shan thanks for the super chat last
credit scene yeah i'll talk about that
zechariah tolson with wanda having dark
golden hair and her kids she's going to
be villain dark strange too
maybe thank you for the super chat
double post credit ohp thanks for the
super chat you see the second bus credit
saying the kids are still alive
kind of thank you for that super chat
kazamir
fenelon
was amazing yeah the design for scarlet
witch was amazing
that i think it's one of the best
outfits in the mcu without question
she she immediately when she transformed
scarlet witch she immediately shot up to
like one of my favorites that was insane
and it was cool how like
her crown was like made out of magic
yeah like at first it was like made out
of magic and stuff like that and it's
just kind of like
i also talked about a cruel fate for
agatha jeez yo
another thing too bro
bro he was ralph pedro was wrapped the
whole time
he's not the fox quicksilver pietro's
ralph he was not he was a regular guy
ralph connor chandler thanks for the
super chat
yeah that was another thing that kind of
shocked me as well
someone sent in the 20 super chat this
episode was such an emotional roller
coaster but omgm speechless
this episode 10 out of 10. but the
favorite part was the family
fight scene yeah officially turning into
scarlet witch yeah
wow the real question is is where's
white vision
that's a big question that is a big
question and then trace mitchell the
five dollar super chat crazy but i think
juan is the next big bad
i think a part of her is going to start
to be possessed by this evil
elder god and i and i think i think it
could be
i think could happen she's tapping into
the dark old man she's stopping
and how reminiscent of her floating in
the air with her legs crossed that's
like
reading the book just like strange yeah
i thought that was so cool
yeah i i also loved the wizard of oz
oh yeah with the the feet under the car
yeah i totally caught that genius oh
yeah
totally genius guys i was just thinking
about this right now someone mentioned
it in my chat
this takes place three weeks after end
game yeah like right after end game it
takes place right after in the game
we still have eight months until the
events are far from home
yeah so like spider-man no way home
could start
and then something massive could have
gone down oh yeah you know we have no
idea
no idea oh man yeah
i just that was that was just so well
done
i can't i can't say enough about it just
dude
top to bottom just yeah so well done
such a great ending
very emotional she got to watch vision
die
oh gosh her arms oh devastating it was
shedding that's here a human i know
cynthoid
hey one second guys i'm gonna mute
myself to acknowledge some super chats
yeah all right sorry guys let me get
these super chats
matthew king what's up bro does this
mean wantedville now i
i think it might i think going to doctor
strange might be a villain
drum and oliver thanks for super chat
white vision will return
i believe so catboy two indians omg
after christopher i know
i was so excited leftist tech support
what if ralph boner is the witness
protection name
for peter maximoff ooh that's a good one
i like that i like that a lot
and thank you for the super chat amanda
gomez who has senior scratch though i
know
thanks to super chat we have to we have
to know that we're alpha submitting with
whistling
missing witness he could still be a
mutant see our vasquez thank you for
super chat i agree
tanya thank you for the 10 super chat
tonya crocker
man i am not getting invested anymore
disney plus so such huge point with zero
tying up of any story threads let's be
honest yeah i
think it depends on how you you view it
i i definitely can see how it could be
disappointing for some people and for
the people who are disappointed
i get it right i i get it but i think
i think
i think it's going to set up a lot which
is kind of what i was worried about
was that it's gonna it's gonna just set
things up
it wrapped up westview which is what
they said it was gonna do so
um i think falcon winter soldier will be
much more straightforward
charles hayes where's the cameo it was
himself he was joking with us it was
it was himself it was white vision so he
trolled us
tim wonder thanks for the super chat
disappointed as well
yeah they didn't explain ralph petro
scratchy no doctor strange engineer
barely sell money user powers how did
agnes get the offer up from coulson
don't don't count agents of shield
as cannon uh don't don't thank agents of
shield as cannon
so she didn't take it from coulson
uh bradley jones thanks for the super
chat who wants to see monica who is the
scroll girl referring to
it's it's either talos or nick fury
probably nick fury because
because remember in the end credits
apart from home
a far from home uh
he's in space remember that
agatha agata thank you so much for the
super chat
so guys hey wait hold on can we just
talk about we have almost
7 000 people let's go
at 7 000 on my part so we have 14
000 people what up yo so a lot of people
in my super chat
are talking so ralph ralph
is probably the person in witness
protection could he be in witness
protection because he is indeed a mutant
because because we saw him
using his speed now did that thing that
was controlling
him the necklace did did that give him
powers or
was it just controlling him right so now
is that question right
is he actually an x-men is actually
quicksilver from our universe
but does he have those powers what was
was that necklace giving him powers or
do you have powers
i think the necklace controlled him yeah
yeah and not gave him
you you think it gave him powers then no
i don't think he
i i don't think it gave him powers i
think they just made it very clear that
he's just like a regular guy that
well then how did he move around like
quicksilver i think that was a
separate she gave him powers yeah she
basically turned him into pietro
gotcha james schultz thanks for the
super chat
she hears her sons are alive so you so
she'll use the dark hole to tear open
the multiverse that's uh
that's actually pretty good dude but
another question who is that prediction
there
those those children were like screaming
at the end like in pain bro
yeah they were like suffering well okay
so if we want to tie it back to mephisto
or
have a dimension right they went back
because they were actually shards of
mephisto or whatever so where did they
go
back to daddy right because daddy's
somebody
right and bro and this could be
multiverse
madness wanda on the quest of getting
back her kids yeah
maybe yeah vodafone thanks for the super
chat this was essentially the snap of
the fox versus agents of shield
took elements with quicksilver and
darkhold definitively ended them
oh yeah for sure oh i agree with you on
that yeah it was no no more
agents of shield that is not canon to
our mcu at all
neither is the fox universe ben steen
thanks for the super chat it says your
match
message was redacted retracted so i'm
sorry if i
if i missed that uh
bumbo what's up man
yeah so i mean how are you guys doing
okay
yes chris is 20 foot away from me in the
other end
yeah the animator what wtf happened to
supervision dude he just bounced
white vision just said peace like oh
what's up i'm the real vision
like i'm out matthew king thanks for
super chat
someone on twitter said um that second
end credit scene
had to be directed by sam raimi yeah
right yeah
very good question brought up by matthew
king thanks for super chat do you think
this hurts the chances of spider-man
multiverse
on no way home uh no way
i don't think so no way yeah i i i i
don't think so i think
you know cause it is mcu but you still
have to think that like sony property
and stuff like that i mean
um abolish thanks for the 10 super chat
i feel very yeah bro they're banned on
twitter man
go scarlett yeah rip your cleo theory
yeah but clea could still show up dottie
wasn't clear that was a big theory
going on right the um
but yeah yo senior scratchy we never
got any word of that and thank you tim
wonder for the super chat we never got
one anything for senior scratchy
i owe people money yeah right harry
matthews
super chat looks like multiverse around
turn second post credit scene yeah it
could be
i'm definitely watching this over a few
times before i do my breakdown and stuff
like that you know like
it's just kind of crazy i mean it it
it's crazy to like what we thought was
gonna happen
and what happened it really is
um the gamer thanks for super chat i
wonder why white division didn't go live
with wanda in the end scene he knows
everything
um who knows what he wants to do but it
means something right i think we can all
agree that it means something
white visions he leaves that's only so
he can come back later sometime
boys i just thought okay we don't know
where
white vision went right armor wars
oh maybe maybe that has something to do
with it
maybe that yeah that one makes sense
chandler thanks for the super chat
scarlet witch is the ultimate magical
being and vision is the ultimate
technological being
oh yeah yes um chandler i think that the
the second post-credits scene that sets
up the multiverse of madness
oh for sure yeah i think she heard her
kids from a different multiverse or the
hell dimension different dimensions
something like that
uh if one this is a good question for
everybody who's wondering
game boy 98 things for super chat if
wanted vision takes place three weeks
after in game
then when does far from home take place
i believe it takes place six months
after in game guys
right yeah spider-man far from home
yeah it's like six to eight months after
avengers in game
lord during thanks for that five dollar
super chat dude i lost my voice
amazing what a show yo what a show
that's true
someone said how did darcy dip in like
two seconds after crashing into hayward
darcy darcy just came into this episode
rammed into hayward and we never saw her
ever
drummond oliver um yeah he could be
fact-checking those thank you for that
super chat
white vision we have not seen the end of
white vision at all by
any means he is still in it marley
redway thank you so much for that super
chat
who was the aerospace engineer it was
that it was major
goodner so no one
no one really specific unfortunately
pirate man could have senior scratchy
have been agatha's familiar yes i
believe it would
i believe so and thank you for that
super chat
marley redway the mid credit scene was
such a waste and disappointment to be
honest
monica won i can see how you think that
i can see how people think that and yeah
they could have done a lot more
that was definitely a set up for secret
invasion
alexa thank you so much for that super
chat for sure i think nick fury's as
well but you got an idea
it's totally fury because she points up
and you know
far from home post credit scene i also
hey full honesty
guys my first thought was talos well
right taylor sir taylor's or fury
i thought they're all working together
right well yeah they were all together
i thought talos until she pointed up and
i was like all right
he's a friend of her mom yeah it's fury
there was a
it's a i i am impressed with how
they did everything at the end dude i'm
impressed how coming off of the last
episode
they literally gave the show an ending
and answered so many questions and they
gave us action
they did yeah it was it was it's a short
amount of time it they started from the
beginning which was great
i loved that i loved that it was like
right when she had her kids and she was
like all right magic
magic magic that that dude
bro vision and vision coming in clutch
yeah for real
for real i was like when she was like
vision and he's like grabbing her head
i'm like he's gonna rip your head off do
something it's clearly not vision come
on
like what are you doing okay
yup yup thanks for the super chat says i
loved quicksilver's real name
ralph boner ralph
i love how he's just like i love how
he's like this super chill guy
playing guitar and crap like that like
so funny where are we where's my man
kate where's my man kid
uh huge fan of the vision and vision
dialogue when
so good our vision is like hacking white
vision
and he's just like unlock your memory
life of love life with love why is
gamora
great question thanks for the super chat
uh
i don't want to miss any the carbon
outlaw i actually think that mephisto
will be thanos phase four
i i think so too and i think photons
definitely has big
i think they have big plans for photon
the next king of kings 95 thanks for
super chat
quicksilver's bf or did ralph had speed
powers he didn't even know about i don't
know man
i don't know that's what we're gonna
have to dive into
wanda will still set up the multiverse
so she cracks it going from our kids
doctor strange to vision will be back
when he has fully simulated memories
we'll be back to save one for himself i
agree
by the phone vision sound thank you for
the super chat
neil's van name and thanks for super
chat white vision knows everything is he
going to get dog strength help wanda ooh
that's a good question yeah maybe
thanks for super chat andrew ross thank
you for the 10 super chat
wand and scarlet witch are two entities
now yeah i don't think so
i think she was just it's kind of like
dr manhattan
like kind of in two places at once um
where would strange have been all that
magic going around why wouldn't he come
i think he's coming i think he's
definitely coming soon
alexa alexa minute 46 38 does that mean
the kids are in hell
i think so i really i really think so
and thank you for that super chat
nora this was comparable season game of
thrones
huge build up big letdown i mean it
could have definitely been a lot more
james schultz thank you so much for
super chat def sam raimi hinting easter
egg yeah
the movie marquee and town square had oz
great and powerful yep
totally jojo burger 12 15. thanks for
the super chat that's the little skull
scroll in captain marvel yes it is yes
it is
matt daley thanks for super chat i think
and doctor strange multiverse madness
strange will take wanda to win the gore
mountain figure it all out oh that'd be
cool
yeah and thanks for super chat any
chance maybe ralph got quicksilver
powers from the hex like monica now can
maybe even if it isn't pietro he might
he might be able to
eddie terrell thanks for super chat paul
glad paul bettany's remaining mcu yes
me too the lone brothers bubba came in
this was so disappointing
what they did with evan peters
quicksilver what a potter killer that's
hilarious
yeah no new characters that's sad
daniel puerta that scene when vision
hacked white [ __ ] reminded of avengers
2 and vision blocked all-time internet
yeah that was really cool
chippy chibi thank you so much for that
10 donation i appreciate that
christianity every leak was wrong yeah
pretty much thanks for that super chat
jason wallace you think falcon and
winter soldier will answer the missing
person i think the missing person was
ralph in all honesty
i i guys the more i like read some super
chats and stuff the more i think
the more i think it's definitely the
kids are definitely like in the hell
realm or something
yeah same i agree i really think that's
what it is and especially
since agatha said about the dark hole
and the
and the powers like you have no idea
what you awakened like i think that's
i think that's kathan the evil elder god
or hell maybe they even pun intended
they may even go with mephisto
but i definitely think they're in
some type of hell dimension
agreed being because i mean i've said it
a couple times and i'll say it again
if they're cr if there are shards of
something right because they have to be
part
of someone else not just wanda where
does it all come from right i mean
who knows casey butcher who was a mark
hamill cameo um it was paul bettany has
white vision he
trolled us um good question from
from my chat marvel experts can white
vision still lift thor's hammer
that who knows she's worthy ebd
i i think again i'm gonna go with yes
well so here's a cool question right
here
cool black bro thanks for super chat
would i got to be free if juana
destroyed the heck so wanda did destroy
the hex
i think she just used her powers to
actually put her in somewhat of a mental
prison
like trapped her in that character
yeah honestly dude when she did that the
first thing i thought was like all right
this isn't the last receive of agatha
no no she's coming back for sure and i'm
so glad because what a waste that would
be
what a waste that would be at some point
wanda's gonna not know how to do
something and she's gonna go talk to her
right team magic affinity thanks for
that five bucks i think they're gonna
keep agatha as like a normal citizen in
west view
right that's correct right yeah get out
somehow what a cool character and she
did a great job
who's thank you for that five dollar
super chat
yeah i'm blake thank you for that super
chat great omar i said what they could
do is have another end credit scene at
the end of falcon and winter soldier
just like
other marvel movies have different end
credits scenes yeah i mean
we definitely expect there to be end
credit scenes for the for the falcon of
the winter soldier
i don't know if those would necessarily
set up no way home or multiverse of
madness
the mighty z thank you for the super
chat ralph is probably the guy and when
his protection
and that's not his real name otherwise
why would he laugh at this yeah that's a
very good point too
dark chun gus yoshi think of super chat
do the west view citizen have
rewritten cells now i don't think so i
think i was really wrong about that
unfortunately remember bulldog thank you
for that 5
super chat loretta and tone antonino
ralph uses tommy's powers he was holding
his hands most of the time
he ran fast ralph uses tommy's uh
interesting thank you for the super chat
that's uh
that's uh interesting i'll have to look
at that but he didn't use that at the
end
so i'll have to look more into that
italo de buella phillo thank you for
that final super chat
kevin cyrro did want to learn astral
production and post credit
i think she did that that's a good way
to put that and thank you for that super
chat
x-men forever 82-90 elizabeth olton said
last night that one division teed up her
character for doctor strange too
so post credit scene is probably super
important oh absolutely
absolutely and thank you for that super
chat team magic infinity thanks for that
5
super chat
just looking through these super chats
making sure i don't miss any dark
jungles oh i got that one
money casey mcnatt
i think people got their hopes up too
much expecting people like xavier
magneto or yeah i know
i know we got we got our hopes up
i'm partly to blame for that damon
madement white vision will turn into
wonderment i think that i think so
who's thanks for that super chat oh no
i don't really have any knowledge of
comics but what's happening to
post-credit scene wanda and being in
person
she was learning about the dark hold
she was learning about the dark cold and
kind of learning like astral production
and stuff
that's grind and dedication to your fan
base so it is it's a huge
huge accomplishment hitting 100k subs
epic thank you brother and and warren
you were here since dude i was like 200
subs bro
yeah since the beginning yeah i i knew
though
like the first time soups like emailed
me and i checked out his channel
and i saw like his enthusiasm and
everything i'm like oh yeah this kid's
like
and he's great he was grinding he's like
i'll give you you know some money
if you i'm like nah like i was like nah
hardest working dude i know oh for real
yeah i was like 18 years old
yeah just paying off good for you man
good for you big congrats thank you guys
it's huge man
at the end of the day guys this is it
this ain't about me this is about
us this is about we coming together time
and time again for these watch parties
with our content and guess what i know
what warren's gonna be back
oh yeah he's probably gonna be back all
of us all of us
oh we're getting it oh we're good now
guys
let's go turn the mic up let me
acknowledge some super chats
son thank you so much for the super chat
whose thanks for that
knapsack thank you so much for that
bradley jones thank you so much for the
super chat
i'm gonna get to the questions right now
they said it's picking up right where it
look
uh i don't want to miss any
oda jun's son i think ralph can be
involved strange multi-person man do you
think quicksilver's soul from x-men
chance
mcu no i don't think that unfortunately
um
but i think he could be involved somehow
if he still has like powers or something
like that
uh knapsack thanks for super chat
everyone set themselves up the show
never hyped up engineer that i said two
lines about it
yeah that was kind of on us
bradley jones in the end credit no one
was making teen reading the dark holder
reminded me of strange in his movies
when he was sleeping in reading
exactly that's what that was
i own i end up because max thank you so
much for ten dollars
you're still overlooking something i
think the directors and writers love to
upper hand y'all
what do you think we're overlooking i
mean i'm sure we are but what do you
think it is
kevin b thank you so much for super chat
the ralph name agatha uses probably
is problematic for quicksilver also the
black widow a hint to where dr strange's
oh for sure
we'll have to see what about ralph is
noah a.g
faith christ music thank you so much for
that super chat i love tonight's
finale episode can't wait for falgore
soldier yep we're doing it again
i wish he was there too but we're going
to get strange very soon
david bennett thanks for super chat did
anyone notice that ralph was an actor
and that was his headshot oh yeah
interesting yeah
brandon pifer so what will come next for
white vision uh he's gonna become real
vision again
he's gonna come back for sure one shot
thanks super chat
casting evan peter's really bad made a
joke they should have gotten someone
else
yeah it was kind of weird i wonder if
they're gonna do something else with
them chris berry thank you so much for
the super chat i got that kept saying
that ralph was her husband that's why
ralph was raiding on his girl
yeah that was weird i think that was
just kind of a joke by her in all
honesty
the next king of gangs ninety five hope
to see him in peter's house change too
yeah i really do too i hope they explain
that he's actually somebody
gayle jeremy so is a roberto wanda
creating her sons
again mephisto souls being used set up
for ghost rider oh yeah
that would be really cool that would be
super cool
i suppose he does you're thinking he's
gonna have some like
type of emotional connection an
emotional
connection like his creator since the
beginning yeah that's like his father
well right because if you want to con
like if you think that he yeah if he's
just jarvis what if white vision tries
to bring back ultra
i think with the releasing of his
memories i don't think that would he
would try to do that
uh nicholas prata look at dr strange
multiverse of madness cast please uh the
problem
with like the cast is online is they're
not that reliable
even on imdb some people google castings
yeah you can't trust google castings and
even if you have uh i believe imdb pro
you can go in and change some castings
as well
so that's uh yo so someone mentioned in
my
sense in a super chat i mentioned it
guys when white vision pulled up
they waited like a couple minutes to
reveal his voice and i was like
i thought it was i thought i was spayed
or i know
i was waiting yeah definitely
whoa whoa hey hold on just a second guys
because i just got 129 dollar super chat
from ca castillo thank you so much hey
bro we're from mexico
hey my family's from mexico i'm actually
part mexican thanks for always being
there it's 3am here by the way
never miss a stream overall grade for
the series um
i loved it and i know that it was hyped
up and that's partially our fault
right it's like creators who like
follow all this around i still loved it
i loved i love these streams i love
talking with everybody
like i love coming together i love
guessing what's going to happen and
breaking things down to being over
analytical
like i love all that stuff and i want to
change the thing i
you know i i think this was a good
ending yes
it wasn't as hype as we thought it was
going to be but i still think it was a
good ending
and shout out to all my guys over there
and ladies in mexico
it's 2 a.m here so what were we going to
say
what a show yeah what i was going to say
is that you know
i think to be honest i think like the
the whole over hyping of everything was
just like partially everyone's fault oh
for sure
it was the actors like paul benton he's
saying there was going to be a luke
skywalker
oh gosh i know it was just him you know
it was just like the fans
theorizing and speculating and getting
hype but
at the end of the day again we just got
to take a step back and
and appreciate turn our expectations
appreciations
too matching infinity maybe it's
somebody new but i think he's talking
about fury
the dragonborn what about the cameo um
it was paul bettany himself he trolled
us
yeah i i'm super grateful that we got
these shows when no movies are coming
out i mean
marvel uh i and you know what we can't
expect marvel to do the same thing over
and over again so i thought this was so
great such a great change in refreshing
you know just you know i just think it
was awesome
i don't mind it being different i like
at all
gc nightwalker do you think the powers
and our memories of wiccan and speed
someone would be say what's uh
maybe elijah bell who was cliff
i was gonna look into that thank you for
that super chat eliza i'm gonna look
into that who is jimmy's person i think
it might have been ralph tyler x
i think of that super chat i really
think it could have been ralph i wonder
if they'll ever
reveal that for real i don't know
daniel later is this new white vision
the vision avengers tried to recreate
during infinity war brand new mindstone
i don't think so i don't think so but
we'll see
i'm trying not to miss any super chats
here guys let me
i think i did miss one i'm trying to go
back and find it
it's not letting me go back that far
what the heck
all right honey graham thank you so much
are there harrowing implications for
wanda not only having darkhold but being
so gross in it
yes it will affect her mind especially
with what agatha said you have no idea
what you just unleashed with their
powers
mad 1306 kevin feige wanted to reboot
spider-man for the ncu to tell a
separate mcu spider-man from sony so
he's going to do the same with x-men
reboot for them yeah for sure i agree
with that
aust gallandale i really hope he
pronounced that right i'm sorry if i
didn't but thank you so much for that
five
super chat windows falcon and winter
soldier and
windows falcon and winter soldier in
reference to one division like when does
it take place
um i think it takes place right after
avengers end game as well
and uh it comes out in two weeks from
today
jojo burger what's up you've donated
before thank you so much again for this
super chat here what if they give what
if they gives ralph a wife
i don't know i'm really curious to see
what his character's gonna be you know
i i wonder if he has powers and stuff
like that you know what i mean
they wouldn't have cast evan peters just
for nothing you know be weird
mr bc thanks for that super chat what if
falcon winter soldiers start to meet
mutants in their show i hope so and i
actually think they will
i really do because of madrapore george
w
bush the george w bush so jimmy woon the
comics knows melinda may
do you think they might tie in agents of
shield uh no
i think agents of shield is a completely
separate entity sadly
who is cliff anyone specific from the
comics
so yeah jimmy wu called cliff i don't
i've been getting questions about that
too
i'm gonna have to go and watch ant-man
on the wasp again
and figure out what that was about and
uh beast mode
54.92 thanks for that super chat we'll
have to research that
i wonder if it's anyone's significant
off off the top of my head
i can't recall anyone from the comics
named cliff yeah i don't i don't
remember honestly
if you said clint i would have known who
was talking about
but uh she's been watching her concert
for a minute and the last credit scene
was from the new zealand
boom it was credited with the news
locations
right before the scene sweet cool thanks
justin i love new zealand
agatha stated that the scarlet witch is
stronger than the sorcerer's supreme
wanda stronger than doctor strange
confirmed i think so i think it's like
yeah and uh no it's not even close no
and danny tf thanks for that super chat
i think that she just needs to learn and
and now that she has a dark hold i think
she's going to like a thousand percent
be stronger
because it's going to be like you know
dude it's gonna be insane insane magic
and she's got the chaos magazine man
right
she's so it's gonna be insane oh
oh sorry i was just gonna say mama jazzy
thanks again for super chat makes a good
point
marvel probably wrote you know all these
phase four
stories before they got the rights back
to fox
um so mutants might not come in phase
four
um i think you can always re-rate things
is what i would say
um you know as you go on
um i i would expect mutants in phase
four i would
especially through they threw spider-man
into civil
war that's true they just threw him in
the civil war
literally nowhere yeah and um another
thing too man is that
when it came to like the whole hex like
we don't know
the effects that hex had on all of his
people like they could ex
george h i i see where you're coming
from for sure
i'm sorry you thanked this episode
sucked there were a lot of story lines
though i think they're gonna
finish those later on down the road
steven
who do you think left the map to the
house with the heart that caused her to
create the hex
no no no that was vision he was gonna
actually buy that house in real life for
them
and start a family hold on real fast
we have so much content for like such a
long time
well i was gonna say at least for the
next two weeks that we'll have
completely new
content to start but uh guys
this was awesome
yep yep
100 and thank you to soups shout out to
soups
100k today on youtube 100k on youtube
today
a lot of exciting stuff
never up not even yeah it's coming
yep
daniel gail thank you so much for that
gonna be honestly this episode at this
point
a lot i guess fan theories hyped too
much yeah
good into the series i like you said yes
edgar
lizarraga
no i hope it's not false either and i
don't think it will be i think we're
good on that one
cliff garner the marvel database website
he's an investigative reporter well
check that out
sorry i was just into that super chat
there um
jabber 27 i love the design of square
which outfit it was insane wasn't it so
cool
wasn't it so cool i loved it
i'm sorry let me get these few super
chats tyla
thank you for that super chat i think i
just commented on
uh daniel gale i'm sorry it wasn't you
know what
i think we all expected a lot you know
and um
it's hard when we are expecting so much
and we don't get what we thought it was
going to be but overall i think it was
pretty good
the source of supreme said that strange
is meant to be the strongest among us so
we haven't even seen stranger the
strongest i 100
agree jonathan sanchez and thank you so
much for that super chat
kevin tran reps probably not his real
name if he was put on
witness protection for jimmy is handler
then it's just new identity i agree
i think it might actually be pietro dr
doctor thanks for that super chat
do you think wanda is going to be a
villain and two personalities of good
and evil ooh that's a good way of
looking at it
um but i think she was like astral
projecting
it's kind of what she was doing like
strange was doing like how he would
study and sleep
but i do think she might be evil just
for a bit maybe not like entirely like
just for a little bit not strange
multiverse madness
prash goon squad welcome back hello from
india will want to be villain in the
future
uh i think like i just said for a little
bit in in one division just for like
like a tiny bit and then i think strange
is going to help her out
and then i think it's going to be all
good i think this would be good
um make sure you don't miss any super
chats here
logically if wanda wanted to study magic
she would just go to dr strange much
easier
a lot of access to knowledge but she
didn't it's like she knows he won't
approve of her studying the darkhold
zcy9951 thanks for that 10 super chat i
think you're 100 right
i think you're 100 right and i also
think like due to the fact that she
doesn't really know him
like they probably briefly met at tony
stark's funeral
right um but that would be like the
first time and
maybe she maybe after she didn't really
care to know him or learn anything about
like the sorcerer's supreme because it's
clear
that she like isn't that magical right
or like she is but you know she just has
these powers that she thought all along
were given to her by the
infinity stone so i think you're right
there though
gc nightwalker assuming that ralph boner
is actually a speedster is it possible
that quicksilver's also mantle like
scarlet witch
um destined to be born together and
powers pass
on when he dies early oh that's a good
theory
gc knight walker but i don't know
i don't know what feige would do i feel
like feige would keep it like
pietro maximoff is quicksilver you know
what i mean
i don't think it would be a mantle i
really like that thinking but i don't i
don't think so
anthony roman two things about how wanda
looking like dana's attending an opinion
war
if you look at the end credits with
wanda she has little portals around her
hair
i think that's multiverse purple portals
anthony roman i agree
i think those are multiverse portals
around her at the end
definitely thanos vibe she could kill
she could have killed thanos and they
confirmed that in the show
strange jay who do you think created the
ark reactor in white vision yeah
you know it's definitely a reactor isn't
it it's a curious thing to
to see vincent rodriguez what did akatha
mean
by you have no idea what you just did i
think that's c'thun i think i think
she unleashed the ancient elder god
jonah uste i think no way home will
start off with one accidentally opening
up the multiverse and doctor strange
coming in helping wanda
yeah and him coming and helping peter
parker too because we know he's going to
be in that right
now for everyone he's like talking about
wanda being the villain
i think with the dark hold
and with her powers
she is going to be
like possessed i i do think she's going
to be kind of possessed
um i think it's the ancient elder god
caton
or like possibly a combination
still yet again uh you know they
mentioned nightmare
they said nightmare i shouldn't say they
mentioned him they didn't mention the
villain nightmare but they said
nightmare
um
i think there's for example when she
heard the kids at the end
um i think they were trapped inside of
possibly the hell realm
because they could be shards of mephisto
i think there's definitely a bigger
enemy coming and i think that's what
agatha meant to answer that super chat
i think that's what agatha meant by you
have no idea what you did
unlocked that's gotta be
this it's gotta be katan the evil elder
god because he created the dark hole the
book that she did confirm was darkhold
so i think that's a big bad coming or at
least a huge villain
in doctor strange and multiverse and
madness so
guys having said that this was awesome
we're gonna be here
uh for falcon and the winter soldier we
are 100 doing watch parties again
this was so much fun um i
i can't believe how much fun this was
especially because i always kind of
feared live streaming i don't know why
um but it was so much fun this was
really really good this was like really
really great uh let me acknowledge the
super chat
lovey edgar thank you so much i got to
push her
into becoming scarlet witch why is she
all surprised
that's a good point that's a good point
i think agatha wanted the power though
you know i think she thought since she
was like such an old experienced witch
and
wanda didn't really know that much that
she could maybe trick her and try to get
the power from her
um i think that's maybe why but guys i'm
wrapping up here so and my stream is a
little delayed
so don't super chat anymore because
i don't want to miss it when i get off
since it's a little delayed so let's end
the super chats right now we will be
back here
in a couple of weeks for falcon in the
winter soldier so
don't worry um
that's a good point yen carlo agnes said
a spell can't be undone
and she put a spelling wrap to make him
quicksilver so does he sell powers maybe
very well cosmic culture
that's chris with the five dollar super
chat thank you
vincent rodriguez is magneto still in
the picture yes
i just because he didn't pop up here
does not mean he's not going to pop
up and i still think they might go with
the story
that he's wanda's father i think this
was house of bim
right it was a lot of things but mainly
house of bim with the different
realities created and stuff like that
and magneto's a really big part of house
of m and the mutants are coming in fact
the
illuminati yeah they released a report
today that said
um a movies in the works right now work
entitled the mutants
are coming i think this is just the
start of it man i think i think
i think the mcu is about to be crazy
awesome
the eternals are going to be so
different one division was so different
falcon and soldier's going to be action
jam-packed and they're going to magipore
which has a huge x-men mutant connection
uh so magneto's hundred percent of the
picture still 100 the picture still
but guys i have a lot to break down
because this was a huge finale
so i'm gonna go i'm gonna watch this
again i'm gonna watch it probably like
two or three more times
take notes write down everything i think
break it down
all that stuff so expect a video for the
breakdown i would say probably
it's 2 30. i would say probably like six
hours six seven eight eight thirty yeah
i would say probably about six hours
gonna get that video out as soon as you
possibly can this was awesome
um the whole experience was awesome
whether you enjoyed the
the finale or not or you enjoyed the
series or not the whole thing was
awesome
um it was awesome to talk with all of
you each night
thank you everybody who showed up we had
a lot of viewers through this whole
entire thing
and i was actually surprised but it was
a lot of fun i
love to hear from you guys thank you
everybody who did super chats tonight
thank you everybody who was commenting
and showed up
all awesome all awesome i think you know
if you were disappointed in the finale
take away the good things from it right
the costume was awesome for the scarlet
witch
there's a lot of really cool fights the
fight between white vision and
regular vision was amazing um it was
emotional
like there's some good things take away
even though it wasn't about
you know what we thought it was you know
pedro being from the fox x-men universe
all that stuff you know
just take the good because there's
always good and bad so focus on that
good but
like i said gonna get started on this
breakdown
i think you hey legendary one
i can't wait for my video i'm gonna get
started right now thank you for always
showing up in my videos you guys are
awesome all right guys
this is it we're getting out of here
expect my breakdown and i would say
probably like six hours maybe
maybe a little more because this is
probably going to take a lot to dissect
and i'm kind of tired so
but i'll get it out i'm going to start
it right now i'm going to re-watch this
thing a few times
take notes and get it all done so i'll
see you guys
next time it'll be two weeks i might do
a watch party for
avengers assembled depending on what
that's really gonna be like so
i'll let you guys know but no matter
what see you guys in two weeks for the
falcon and the word soldier
watch party as always thank you all so
much for watching i truly appreciate
everybody who came out tonight all the
super chats all the support